I'm about to play bubble football which
let's be honest it's possibly one of the
most ridiculous games of football it's
possible to play but it is not the most
ridiculous game of football in history
that goes to 1994 and the Caribbean Cup
match between Barbados and Grenada when
in dumb climate
Barbados went into that match oh you
know I'm gonna tell this story later
a 1994 Caribbean couple it is Barbados
versus Grenada Barbados need to win by
two clear goals in order to qualify just
winning isn't good enough so in they go
by halfway through the match they're up
to nil but with just seven minutes left
Grenada pull one back and it is 2 1
which means Barbados despite winning the
match ain't going through they haven't
won by two clear goals now there's a
stupid rule in this particular
tournament that if a match is drawn it
goes to extra time right over time as
the Americans call it and then ends on
the first goal which counts double
counsel to so Barbados realize hold on
we're two on down if we just score an
own goal equalizer score we're gonna
have half an hour of extra time in which
we just need to score one goal to go
through because this stupid W so they do
then own goal in their own net two more
and then with three minutes left
Grenada realize hold on they need to win
by two goals it doesn't matter whether
the score is three to four to three we
don't go through either way as long as
we score somewhere so for three minutes
Grenada are desperate trying to score
either goal or an own goal because both
will let them trip and they don't manage
it it goes right to time
Barbados call the golden goal and
Barbados goes through and the moral of
the story is this but if you want to
avoid ridiculous games of football or
any kind of game you're changing the
rules make sure you test them thoroughly
first what economists call perverse
incentives
[Music]
that cleaner or not is something from
the world of sport also don't they have
covered before that you might not have
enough
you